[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام الى حلقه جديده
من مستقبل الطاقه هذه الملفاتنا
اوروبا منقسمه حول السقف السعري للغاز
الروسي
ولماذا حذرت وكاله الطاقه الدوليه اوروبا
من شتاء بارد في 20 23
[موسيقى]
الخلافات وعلى اشدها بين دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي حول مقترح وضعي سقف لاسعار الغاز
الروسي وهذا ما ادى الى فشل اجتماعي وزراء
الطاقه الاوروبيين يوم الثلاثاء الفائت
وتحديد موعد جديد للاجتماع في التاسع عشر
من الشهر الجاري الخلاف يدور بين دول
متحمسه للسقف السري من بينها اليونان
وبلجيكا وايطاليا وبولندا لحمايه
اقتصاداتها من اثار ارتفاع فواتير الطاقه
ودول متشككه مثل المانيا والنمسا وهولندا
هذه الدول تتخوف من اي يؤدي فرض السقف
السعر على الغاز الروسي الى تحول شحناته
الى اسواق اخرى مبدا السقف السعر بات مسلم
به لكن الخلافه يدور الان حول مستوياته
وكيفيه تفعيله اخر المقترحات الذي تقدمت
بها تشيكيا يقضي في تفعيل السقف السعري
اذا تجاوزت الاسعار 200 يورو لكل ميغاوات
ساعه لثلاثه ايام متتاليه مع شرط اخر
يتعلق بالفارق بين سعر غاز الانابيب
واسعار الغاز المسال هذا المقترح اعلى من
المقترح السابق الذي تقدمت به المفوضيه
الاوروبيه عند سعر 275 يورو للميجا وات
ساعه لكنه لا يزال اعلى بكثير من طموحات
الدول المتحمسه للسقف السعري المفارقه هنا
ان الخلاف حول السقف ياتي بعد ان تجاوزت
اوروبا عمليه المخاوف من نقص امدادات
الغاز في الشتاء هذا الشتاء بفضل امتلاء
خزاناتها دعونا نشرح كيف حصل ذلك خلال
العام الحالي انخفض استهلاك اوروبا من
الغاز بشكل كبير الى نحو 360 مليار متر
مكعب وفقه تقديرات وكاله دوليه انخفاضا من
مستويات
مليار متر مكعب في العام الماضي 20 21
الذي شهد ذروه الاستهلاك الاوروبي والفضل
في ذلك يعود الى اجراءات ترشيد الاستهلاك
من جهه والطقس المعتدل اكثر من المعتاد في
الخريف كما كان من حسن حظ اوروبا تباطؤ
الطلب الصيني على الغاز المسال هذا العام
لكن وكاله الطاقه الدوليه حذرت في تقرير
لها من ان القاره العجوز لم تخرج من دائره
الخطر فبحسب تقديرات وكاله الطاقه قد
تواجه اوروبا عجنا في امداداته غاز بنحو
27 مليار متر مكعب في العام 20 23 في
سيناريو تنخفض فيه شهر شحنات الغاز من
روسيا الى الصفر عبر الانابيب وتعود
والردات الغاز الطبيعي المسال الى الصين
الى مستويات عام 20 21
[موسيقى]
في هذا السياق المدير التنفيذي لوكاله
الطاقه الدوليه دكتور فاتح بيرو كان حاضرا
في الاجتماع الاوروبي يوم الثلاثاء وكانت
له كلمه لافته استعرض فيها التحديات التي
تواجه امدادات الغاز الاوروبيه في الشتاء
العام المقبل 20 23 والاسباب التي يمكن ان
توقع السوق في عجن كبير
جروب انجليزي
اب تويوتا
نيويورك
وزاره النوبه
اتوقف الان مشاهدينا مع فاصل قصير وتابع
بعده مناقشه التحديات الاوروبيه في ملف
الغاز في مقابله مع خبير اسواق الغاز
والهيدروجين في اوابك وائل عبد المعطي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اذا اوروبا باتت في مامن
من نقص الغاز هذا الشتاء لكن التحديات
الاوروبيه في اداره ملف اعدادات الغاز
مازالت كبيره على المداين البعيد والقصير
فهناك قرارات استراتيجيه لابد من اتخاذها
على الصعيد الالتزام بعقود شراء الغاز
المسال على المدى البعيد وهناك مساله
السقف السعر على الغاز الروسي والذي قد
يترك تاثيرا على الامدادات العمل المقبل
هذه الملفات ناقشتها مع خبير اسواق الغاز
والهيدروجين في اوافق السيد وائل عبد
المعطي وسالته بدايه عن ما اذا كان الشتاء
العام المقبل هو الامتحان الحقيقي لاوروبا
شكرا جزيلا يا استاذ ناصر ومجدده شكرا على
استضافه على برنامجكم مميز في قناه
العربيه
والعوده على السؤال اللي حضرتك طرحته هو
بالفعل الاتحاد الاوروبي بشكل او باخر نجح
في تحقيق الهدف اللي وضعته المفوضيه
الاوروبيه وهو الوصول الى اكثر من 80% قبل
حلول فصل الشتاء في العام الجاري وكان تم
وضع تاريخ 1 نوفمبر وليس فقط تحقيق الهدف
بالنجاح الدول الاوروبيه مجتمعه في تجاوز
هذا الهدف بدل 80% الى 95 في ال 100 ايضا
في الاول في نوفمبر ومع دخول بطبيعه الحال
همم فصل الشتاء وبدايه موجه البرد في معظم
الدول الاوروبيه بدا السحب من هذا المخزون
فنقدر نقول ان الشتاء الحريق استطاعت
المفوضيه الاوروبيه من خلال الهدف لو
وضعته سابقا بالاضافه الى بعض العوامل
الاخرى اللي اخذتها في الاعتبار ويتحسن
ظروف الطقس همم قد تستطيع تخطي فصل الشتاء
الجاري همم لكن هتبقى معطله في الفصل
الشتاء القادم اللي هو هيكون هو الاختبار
الحقيقي لعده اسباب اللي احنا ممكن نلخصها
في ثلاث اسباب رئيسيه بسبب الاولاني ان
الغاز الروسي كان اوريدي وصل او بالفعل
اللي كان وصل في في عام 2022 وده هيكون
اقل في العام المقبل بنسبه يعني هتتراجع
بنسبه اكثر من 50% السبب الاخر ان اا جانب
الاوروبي يعني ابدا الى زياده همم رفع
وارداته من الغاز الطبيعي المثال بشكل
كبير ومن الصعب ان هو يؤدي او يحقق زياده
ايضا في زياده ولادته خلال العام المقبل
بسبب الاخير ربما يتوقف ما يتبقى من
انجازاته من انغاز الروسي في خلال عام 20
23 وده هيشكل تحدي كبير ل- الدول
الاوروبيه لرفع المخزونات وصولها الى
الهدف الوضاعتهم المسبقا اا 80% قبل بدايه
فصل الشتاء من اي حاجه
البيانات تشير الى ان الاتحاد الاوروبي
استطاع ايضا خفض استهلاكه من الغاز خلال
شهرين اكتوبر ونوفمبر بنحو 24% مقارنه
بمعدل هذين الشهرين للسنوات الخمس الاخيره
طبعا ساعدهم في ذلك درجات الحراره التي لم
تنخفض بنفس الحده المعتاده ولكن لاجتياز
شتاء العام المقبل هذا يعني انهم مضطرون
ليس فقط الاستمرار بخفض استهلاكههم خلال
هذا الشتاء بل حتى خلال صيف السنه القادمه
صحيح
نعم صحيح هو خلينا نضع الاول تسلسل
الاحداث هو المفاضله الاوروبيه اتخذت قرار
في العام الجاري في بعد بدايه الازمه
الروسيه الاوكرانيه بتوجيه معظم الدول
الاوروبيه او كافه الدول في الاتحاد لفظ
الطلب على الغاز بالادراء استثنائي بنسبه
15% وبدات بالفعل لكل الدول الاعضاء في
الاتحاد الاوروبي همم اخذ هذا القرار محل
الاعتبار وبدا فعلا تخفيض واللي بدا تظهر
ملامحه في احد الشهور الاخيره مثل شهر
اكتوبر او شهر نوفمبر وعلى هذا الاساس اا
تراجع حتى طلب على الغاز في بعض القطاعات
زي القطاع المنزلي بنسبه 15% وفقا
لتقديراتنا في منظمه في الاوامر وكذلك
ايضا حوالي 15% في القطاع الصناعي
وبالنسبه طفيفه في قطع الكهرباء
اتخذته المفوضيه الاوروبيه همم كان
القراءه استثنائي وخافض استثنائي 15%
ينتهي همم حلول همم مارس من العام المقبل
20 23 لكن بالنظر الى المعطيات الظروف الح
قد تضطر المفاوضيه الاوروبيه مجددا الى
اعاده تفعيل هذا القرار ومن ثم همم اعاده
همم محاوله تخفيض الطلب على الغاز لحتى
تتمكن من ملء المخزونات قبل بدايه شتاء
عام 20 23 20 24 ما زال اعضاء الاتحاد
الاوروبي في حاله عدم توافق حول مساله وضع
سقف سعر على اسعار الغاز بالرغم من
المفاوضات الطويله والمستمره هل برايك
مهندس وائل ان وضع هكذا سقف ساري قادر على
النجاح الا ان يدفع هذا البائعين لتحويل
شحنتهم الى مناطق ودول اخرى حيث الاسعار
اعلى رايك في الحقيقه ايضا همم هذا
الاجراء من جانب المفوضيه الاوروبيه هو
لسه لم يترجم الى قرار ملزم لكن دعنا همم
نضع في البدايه همم اين الجدل داخل
المفوضيه الاوروبيه هناك مجموعه من الدول
تؤيد هذا القرار وهو وضع سقف على اسعار
الغاز همم باعتبار ان ده هيؤمن او هيمن-
يعني اقتصاداتها من ارتفاع تكاليف وهناك
مجموعه اخرى معارضه لهذا القرار التي تراه
ان هو يؤدي هيهدد استقرار اسواق الطاقه في
الجانب الاوروبي يمكن دعامهم ايضا للبنك
الاوروبي مؤخرا بتصريح لي بان ارتفاع او
وضع سقف لارتفاع اسعار الغاز اا قد يؤدد
الاستقرار المالي في اوروبا لكن ايضا من
جانب الدول المؤيده لهذا القرار هناك
مجموعه معترضه على السقف الموضوع في الوقت
الحالي وهو بالمناسبه حوالي 275 همم يورو
لكل ميجا واتساب ساعه وده يكافئ تقريبا
حوالي 84 دولار لكل مليون واحده حراريه
بريطانيه الحقيقه ان هذا القرار على هذا
السقف المقترح هو مرتفع جدا ويصل حتى الى
ضعف همم اسعار الغاز اللي وصلت لها همم
اسواق الاوروبيه في اوجه الازمه او في
اوجه التراب امدادات الغاز من روسيا بمعنى
ان هذا استغفر ربما حتى لو تم تطبيقه مش
هيكون فيه اليه للتنفيذ على الارض لان
السقف مرتفع حوالي 275 يورو لكل ميجا
واتساب ساعه ومتوس حتى الاسعار الغاز على
مدار عام 2022 حوالي 130 ااا يورو لكل
ميجا وات ساعه معناها ان السقف المقترح في
الوقت الحالي يزيد الى الضعف القيمه اللي
اوريدي يحققها او بالفعل حققها خلال 20 22
من ناحيه اخرى فانت ال- اا اي سلعه في سوق
يعني فيها في حاله ندره مثل حاله الغاز
الطبيعي من الصعب ان اي اا مشتري يضع
عليها سقف طالما ان سلعه في حاله مضر لان
ببساطه كم اشرت حضرتك هيؤدي الى توجه هذه
السلعه الى همم الى اسواق اخرى بتاعنا
ساعه اعلى
الاتحاد الاوروبي يبحث ايضا اطلاق برنامج
او اليه مشتركه لشراء الغاز بشكل جماعي
للاستفاده من خصومات سعريه
ناتجه عن تجميع الطلب الاوروبي على الغاز
تحت مظله واحده
هل هكذا اليه قابله للتطبيق اصلا من
الناحيه اللوجستيه وهل سيقبل منتج هو
بائعون الغاز التفاوض على البيع من خلال
هكذا تجمع
ايه وفي الحقيقه ايضا استاذ ناصر هذا
السؤال مهم جدا وهو من احد الاسئله
المطروحه في السوق العالمي للغاز من
الناحيه اللوجستيه هو ممكن اي مشتري اي
باقه يعني اي مشتري للسلعه بيعرض الطلب
بتاعه بيحدد الكميه المطلوبه ونقطه
التسليم
وبائع السلعه بيحدد اا مدى امكانيه تلبيه
هذا الطلب
وتحديد نقطه التسليم وتاريخ التسليم
والاتحاد الاوروبي بشكل عام او الدول
الاوروبيه بتتميز بان لديها شبكات همم
تربط الدول ببعضها البعض وبالتالي تتستطيع
همم اوروبا اعاده توجيه هذه الكميات من
خلال نقطه التسليم اللي بيتم استلام في
الكميه الى اي دوله من همم دول داخل
الاتحاد الاوروبي انما الهدف همم بشكل
اساسي من هذه الاله اللي همم كما حضرتك
اشرت لها همم للمفاضيه الاوروبيه هو
محاوله تجميع هذا الطلب من خلال همم معرفه
متطلبات المشتريين الاوروبيين وهمم وكان
هذه او همم ارسال هذه الكميات الى مزود
خدمه بتعيين من جانب المفوضيه الاوروبيه
اللي هو هيكون بمثابه كانه هو المشتري
الوحيد اللي موجود في السوق الاوروبي همم
ده انا اعتقد ان هيكون في اختبار للسوق
همم يفترض ان احنا داخل السوق الاوروبي في
سوق اا سوق تنافسي سوق حر في عدد كبير من
المشتريين في عدد كبير من البائعين وهي دي
اليات السوق المعتاده او اساسيات السوق
المعتاده وهي عمليه العرض والطلبه واللي
بيخضع فيها السعر في النهايه الى عمليه
التوازن بين العرض والطلب همم اعتقد ان
المفوضيه الاوروبيه همم يعني هاقطعها تطلق
همم شكل من اشكال الاختبار ومدى استجابه
البائعين هذا الامر ربما لن يفضله بعد
منتج الغاز على اعتبار ان هيكون في تحديد
سعر وده مش هيؤدي الى المنافسه الكافيه
وقد تتجه ايضا هذه الشحنات اللي همم لدى
المنتجين الى مناطق اخرى بتعرض سعر افضل
بما يتوائم مع اساسيات السوق من العرض
والطلب ف- نقدر نقول ان ال- همم ان
البدايه اهو توقعاتنا احنا حتى في منظمه
هيتم اختبار السوء بكميه بسيطه جدا في
الاول وهمم رؤيه مدى استجابه السوق له
كميه ومن ثم قد تستطيع من فضائل الاوروبيه
انها تعتمد على هذه الاليه بشكل كبير او
همم الانتهاء منها تماما يعني في المقابل
مهندس وائل واردات الاتحاد الاوروبي من
الغاز المسال الروسي ارتفعت بنحو 40% خلال
الاشهر العشره الاولى لهذا العام مقارنه
بنفس الفتره من العام الماضي هل حقا
اوروبا تنجح في خفض استهلاكها من الغاز
الروسي ولماذا الامتناع عن غاز الانابيب
الروسي الارخص ثمن وشراء الغاز المسال
الروسي الاعلى ثمنا همم نعم صحيح هو
بالفعل همم بياناتنا حتى احنا في منظمه
الاوراق وجدنا ان في ارتفاع في والدات همم
دول الاتحاد الاوروبي من الغاز الطبيعي
المثال من روسيا خلال الشهور التاسع
الاولى من عام 20 22 مقارنه بنفس الفتره
من العامل همم السابق 20 21 وتقديراتنا
حتى النسبه دي تصل الى 50% زياده في همم
في النمو لدول الاتحاد وفي بعض الاسواق
همم زي اسباني او زي بلجيكا وهولندا كان
في زياده ملحوظه في هذه الكميه فاجابه على
هذا السؤال هل يستطيع الجانب الاوروبي
التخلص تماما من الغاز الروسي هو بشكل او
اخر نجح في تخفيض اعتماده على الغاز عبر
الخطوط الانابيب زي نور دستريم او خط
يامال انما من خلال الغاز الطبيعي المثال
لم يتمكن الاتحاد الاوروبي من التخلص من
الغاز الروسي بل على العكس زاد اعتماده
عليه اما ما هو السبب همم لجوءه الى الغاز
الطبيعي المثال الغالي الثمن هو تخليه عن
همم خطوط الانابيب او خطوط الانابيب رخيص
الثمن هو الحقيقه ده يعكس تباين في
المواقف ما بين الدول الاوروبيه لان الدول
اللي زادت ولادتها من الغاز الطبيعي
المساعد من الجانب الروسي لم تكن اي من
الاساس عملاء لروسيا عبر الخطوط الانابيب
وابرز هم اس- اسبانيا يعني اسبانيا لم
تكون باستعراض الغاز من روسيا عبر خطوط
الانابيب وبالتالي هناك تباهي في المواقف
الاوروبيه ما بين الدول وبعضها البعض اللي
بيعتمد على همم الغاز عبر خطيره الانابيب
بدا يتخلى عنه بالفعل انما لبعض الاخر
الذي لم يكن في السابق يكون ايراد الغاز
الروسي عبر الانابيب لجا الى الغاز
الطبيعي المثال واستورد منه كميات كبيره
مما ادى الى زياده الكميه اللي وصلت
لاوروبا الى اكثر من 50% خلال 9 شهور من
2020 قامت المانيا مؤخرا بتوقيع عقد
لاستيراد الغاز المسال القطري لمده 15
عاما بالرغم انه سابقا رفضت المانيا
التعاقد مع قطر لفتره تتجاوز ال 10 سنوات
ما الذي غير الموقف الالماني وما الدلاله
التي يحملها تغير هذا الموقف لسوق الغاز
المسال اللي غير الواقع الواقع اللي بيفرض
السوق العالمي للغز الطبيعي المثال الذي
يعاني في الوقت الحالي من قيود في
الامدادات النمو في الطلب علاوه على
اولويه امن الطاقه همم بالنسبه للجانب
الالمانيه خلينا نوضح ان هنا المانيا
تعتبر هي اكثر دول الاتحاد الاوروبي تاثرا
بالازمه الروسيه الاوكرانيه لعده اسباب
الاولاني ان المانيا كانت بتعتمد بشكل
كبير يمكن اكثر دوله في دول الاتحاد على
همم
بتاعه الغاز همم من روسيا بالنسبه لتصل
الى 55 الى 60% من اجمالي الطلب المحلي
داخل المانيا على الغاز السبب الاخر لم
تكن تملك المانيا اي همم اي اتصال بالسوق
العالمي لغاز الطبيعي المسال لان لم تكن
لديها بنيه اساسيه لاسطراض الغاز الطبيعي
وبالتالي لما قررت المانيا بشكل او باخر
همم تقرير الاعتماد على الغاز الروسي ومن
ثم حتى تم ايقاف خط النوت 3 1 بدات
المانيا تبحث عن هذه همم البدائل وكان
نتيجه عدم وجود بني اساسيه بدات الحكومه
تطلق برنامج
وتخصص ميزانيه متخصصه لانشاء مرافق
الاستقبال غاز طبيعي المسال وصل في
مجموعها الى خمسه من المتوقع انها تدخل
همم في حيز التشغيل خلال الفتره من شتاء
20 22 وحتى العمل المقبل بس استثمارات حتى
تعودت في البدايه بحوالي ثلاثه مليار
دولار ولكن فعليا قفزت هذه الاستثمارات
الى 10 مليار دولار فبالتالي احنا بنقول
هو واقع فرض السوق وبينعكس هذا على سوء
العالمي احنا نتوقع ايضا في منظمه الاوراق
ان تلجا بعض البلدان الاوروبيه الى تقويه
اتفاقيه طويله المده مع بعض كبار المنتجين
في السوق وده ايجابي لنا كمنطقه عربيه اا
لان ده بيعزز الطلب على الغاز الطبيعي من
المنطقه العربيه اللي تعتبر ايضا من
المناطق المهمه في انتاجه على المستوى
العالمي الاتحاد الاوروبي منذ اشهر وهو
يستثمر بشكل كبير وسريع في بناء قدرات
لاستقبال الغاز المسال ولكن البعض يحذر
بان هذه الجهود لا تتماشى بالتوازي مع
توقيع عقود الاستيراد الغاز المسال طويله
الاجل هل بالتالي هناك مخاطر بان يجد
الاتحاد الاوروبي نفسها يواجه فجوه في
الامدادات خلال العام او العامين القادمين
الاجابه نعم الاجابه نعم نعم هيكون في
فجوه متوقعه ما بين العرض والطلب لكن دعنا
نوضح في البدايه ان الاتحاد الاوروبي وقبل
حتى هذا الاستثمار السريع والفعال في
اضافه قدرات جديده لاستيراد الغاز الطبيعي
المثال ولديه قدرات تصل الى حوالي 175
مليار متر مكعب سنويا من المرافق المنتشره
على الدول الاوروبيه اللي تقع في منطقه
الغرب اا حتى هذا الرقم لم يكن همم
البلدان الاوروبيه تكافئ له عقود طويله
المده لان كان هناك تردد همم لدى بعض
البلدان الاوروبيه همم توقيع عقود طويله
المده للغاز الطبيعي المسائل على اعتبار
ان هناك محاولات للتخلص من الوقود
الاحفوري بالاضافه الى امكانيه دخول
الهيدروجين كعامل مهم في مستقبل الطاقه في
بعض البلدان الاوروبيه وعلى هذا الاساس
حتى ال175 مليار متر مكعب اللي هي قدرات
استقبال غاز طبيعي المسائل اللي كانت
موجوده في عام 20 21 او بدايه عام 20 22
لم يقابلها عقود طويله المده في السوق
العالمي طبعا اضيف اليها ايه المشاريع
اللي تم الاعلان عنها اللي هي تضيف تقريبا
حوالي 40 مليار على هذا الرقم نقطه اخرى
ان السوق العالمي في عام 20 23 هناك ايضا
هيكون في زياده طفيفه في الامدادات ربما
من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ومن بعد
الدول الافريقيه هيكون في زياده نتيجه
مشاريع دخلت بالفعل حيز التشغيل ولكن مش
هيتؤدي الى تحقيق الفائض الكافي اللي قد
تحتاجه الدول الاوروبيه سواء لتخطيط ال
175 مليار الاساسيه او حتى ال 40 مليار
اللي هتضاف فيها 20 22 23 وقد يزداد الامر
صعوبه على اوروبا انعاود همم طلب الصيني
مجددا انه الصين في عام 2022 كان لديها
بعض الاجراءات لتحقيق سياسه صفر كوفيد وده
اثر على طلب الصيني ولكن بدا مؤخرا الصين
تعلن عن اجراءات لتخفيف هذه القيود وربما
الغائها تماما ومن ثم فاحنا نتوقع ان
الصين قد تلتهم الزياده اللي هيشهدها
السوق العالمي في عام 20 23 وبالتالي هذا
ضغط كبير ليه همم الاتحاد الاوروبي في
توفير
او احتياجاتهم
[موسيقى]
هذا مشاهدينا نصير ختام هذه هي الحلقه من
مستقبل الطاقه تابعونا دائما في تويتر
الاستماع
[موسيقى]